thank you thank you first to the Academy
and the board this is a truly great
honor and I have to thank both Tom and
will to receive this award from two of
our greatest talents and two people I am
lucky to be able to call my friends is a
distinct honor of its own as it is to be
here among movie legends mr. Pennebaker
George Stevens and Hal Needham my story
is of mentors people who give of their
time and their talents of their words
and their wisdom people who encourage
all of us to reach for more and in doing
snow inspire us inspire us to strive for
excellence not only in ourselves but in
each other my first mentors my parents
they gave me life and they gave me a
deep appreciation for what it is to give
to others there are days between my
second and third breakfasts when I think
how lucky I was to have been mentored at
such an early age my mom she passed away
a little over a month ago and I I really
regret that I never told her this enough
but my father is here tonight and dad I
want to say now just how much you mean
to me and how much I love and appreciate
you for all you have given to me Mentors
mentors John Lindsay the late great
mayor of New York taught me the power of
believing believing in an ideal for when
he looked out across a sea of problems
and people in need most of whom asked
for nothing
said he wanted to try and make their
world just a little bit better and he
did this was an early lesson in a simple
truth that each of us can and should
make a difference Kirk Douglas
I met Kirk as most of the world did
larger than life on a giant silver
screen Spartacus a true hero then I had
the honor of meeting him in real life
and he was an even larger Hearst larger
hero in person it's Kirk who taught me
you haven't learned to live until you've
learned to give it's a statement that
echoes loudly and it is in many ways the
mantra of Hollywood think of George
Clooney and the Soudan think of Steven
Spielberg and Shoah think of Angelina
Jolie and the United Nations think of
David Geffen well everything the list is
long and I am honored to be among the
many in fact standing here alone doesn't
feel quite right to me it projects a bit
of a false image because mostly all I
did was pick up the phone and ask you
it's you who did it you who give of your
time your talent your money your hearts
because that's what you do
that is what Hollywood does and I know
what it is to be asked I was asked by
Lou and Edie Wasserman mentors they
asked me to take a moment to consider
the motion picture
television fund and the ask was all that
it took a place to care for many of our
nation's great artists and storytellers
a place for mentors to be safe and to be
appreciated you saw their faces heard
their voices in that video and there is
so much more I stand here tonight on
their behalf with particular pride
because this award bears the name of
Jean Herschel
it was he nearly 75 years ago who was
among the founders of the motion picture
Relief Fund I'm tempted to say it's the
circle of life but a circle implies
something complete and we at the fund
have a greater horizon I will end with
the my thanks to the person who is every
single day my greatest mentor we met
back in the John Lindsay days and we are
here today as partners in giving and
partners in living the mother of my
amazing children she is my wife and she
is my life Maryland
and to all of you I want to thank you
again for giving so generously of your
time of your talent and of your hearts
you might say that all of us who work in
the film industry we actually live in
two worlds
there's the imaginary world we project
on the screen and then there's the real
world that we live in everyday all of
the other Oscars they pay tribute to the
talent that goes into the creation of
those imaginary worlds I believe this
particular Hersholt award is a
recognition of the extraordinary
generosity of our industry towards
improving the real world that we all
share
and it is with that in mind and and I
think really on your behalf that I
humbly and proudly accept this amazing
recognition thank you so very much